[Music]
good afternoon folks thank you so much
for joining us this afternoon what we'll
be talking today is about optimizing
block storage quick introductions first
my name is Manu Botha I'm product
manager for TCP persistent disk with me
here is Stanley Fang he's the
engineering manager for persistent disk
focusing mainly on performance couple of
key points and what we'll be discussing
today we want to cover starting with
what is persistent disk a quick
introduction a quick detail around what
are the feature sets where data
management features and data protection
feature sets and getting into
performance so the recommended practices
around how to optimize persistent disk
performance with GC P so what I cover
about some recommendations around them
and then Stanley will also be covering a
specific use case and I'm optimizing my
sequel performance with a new feature
that is released in beta with 16 K
blocks and of course towards the end we
can take questions and afterwards -
we'll be hanging out and please reach
out to us for anything specific starting
with a good introduction around
persistent disk with TCP you get many
options around how you store data you
get databases and many kinds of
databases with in-memory relation
databases no sequel later their houses
and on the storage side may a block
object and file in this session we're
mainly focusing on block storage for GC
b which is persistent disk persistent
disk is a highly durable
high-performance block storage for GC p
and a couple of key facts around block
storage is its simple fast and flexible
the reason I say it's simple flacks and
fast and flexible are around the need of
doing striping how does it do a lot of
the stuff on the back end versus forcing
the customers to do OS level
optimizations it provides a virtual
scuzzy device and it can scale from one
gig to a 64 terabyte size itself getting
into the block storage ties with DCP we
have three different types of block
storage
one is a local SST a local SSD can go up
to three terabytes it's mainly
recommended as a high-performance Scrat
space because it's an epidermal storage
so it's local to the VM and it's
essentially a scratch space and it's
priced around eight cents per gig per
month now when we get into network based
PD we have two different options one is
standard persistent disk and SSD
persistent disk the use cases around
them for standard arm or around large
data processing workloads around
genomics processing and video editing
and it's assessing target towards a
Christ sensitive audience with four
cents per gig per month when we get into
SSD that is focused on our high
performance data bases like my sequel
sequel servers Oracle or any other
database of choice it is persistent and
it it usually runs around 17 cents per
gig per month for the SSD persistent
disk there are some also data management
features around it you can have in it
comes standard with encryption it comes
with snapshots I'm going to talk later
on what different types of snapshots are
there and so the scalability functions
are you can actually have 128 Peary's
per VM and each PD can be around 64
terabytes size couple of common patterns
how we think PD is used generally by
customers you can use PD as a boot
device you can use PD as a boot device
and use it as a read/write volumes for
your VMs Pirie also allows to have an
attached into multiple VMs as a
read-only device Tom will be covering a
couple of more use cases around
specifically how you can use PD for data
distribution around multiple VMs and we
also have a new feature which glazing
soon is around synchronous replicated
PDS across zones so this provides active
active replications across two zones in
the same region in case of a PD failure
and I'll be covering more details in the
following slides on that one to you but
these are the common patterns we see
around how PD is attached to VM for
different workload optimizations
getting more detail into so the data
management features I covered Multi
multi leader support so you can use PD
in a read-only mode to share data across
multiple VMs PD snapshots are geo
replicated it can take regional and
modern regional snapshots and I'll talk
more about that too you can scale
without interruptions so we're talking
about simplicity and flexibility you can
actually scale a PD without having to
detach it you can scale it dynamically
while it's attached and of course all PD
it comes with automatic encryption
across the board getting into more data
protection features PD has snapshots and
the standard snapshots are copied over
into GCS so when you take a first
snapshot it is full and every other
snapshot can be incremental
now once the PD snapshot is taken
you can choose we do want to store them
in a regional bucket or a multi-racial
bucket one of the features that was
asked for a long time and PA just went
into production is around PD snapshot
scheduling with snapshot scheduling you
can actually control the lifecycle of a
snapshot
how many snapshots do you want to take
how often do you honestly I think and
and how often do you want to keep or how
long do you retain them so you can
define a retention policy you can define
a snapshot creation policy and it can
all work offline without having you to
schedule with scripts or other tools
outside of the core PD pieces getting
into a bit more around a snapshot
location snapshot location is a feature
which is in beta and this is more for
customers who are focused around data
locality so if you're taking a snapshot
and you're concerned about that my
snapshot shouldn't leave certain
localities or you want to maintain for
either of compliance or taxation or
different purposes that corporations
have you can actually control it
precisely where your snapshot is stored
you can say my snapshot is taken from us
central and can go to us east one or you
can say my snapshot a stays
us and I will store them in
multi-regional us bucket so this is
truly targeted towards where you want to
control data locality but still want to
control have dr with snapshots another
feature which is going to year of the
month it should be in our blog post to
surround synchronous replication so PD
has regional PD which allows which takes
two copies of a PD in two different
zones and all the rights are
synchronized in the backend so before a
write is sent across back to the host
and acknowledged the write exactly
synchronized across both sides this
particular feature is more targeted
towards applications which are highly
sensitive to response to recovery point
and recovery time objectives now getting
into performance basics we can look at
performance in multiple different
dimensions one dimension that I like to
deep dive is IO density so when you look
at IO ops
PD standard provides 0.75 reads and 1.5
write I ops per gig and this metric is
particularly important if you look at
what's the maximum this size do I need
to achieve the full iOS that I need for
my application
same thing for PD SSD you can get up to
30 I apps per gig and on in the
following charts I'll show you kind of
what's the ramp up for PD size versus
the eye ops and megabytes per second
ramp one of the latest changes around PD
standard is PD standard higher
bandwidths of 180 megabits per second
for read and 124 writes it just moved up
to 240 reads and 240 writes so that
should help with a lot of throughput
sensitive applications for PD SSD we're
looking at one point two gigs per second
reads and 400 megabytes per second right
now I talked about IO density in terms
of megabytes and I ops and if you look
at this chart you literally can reach
peak
throughput in terms of megabytes per
second for a PDS a standard PD but by
attaching a two terabyte drive same
thing for if you are using PD SSD for
i/o sensitive applications you can
achieve the peak with two terabyte also
so that essentially means you can
actually optimize for throughput or
megabytes per second or throughput or I
offs depending on what your application
needs without having tons of spare
capacity to get to that max number
another criteria when looking at what
are the different thresholds to achieve
the peak performance is how was the size
of VM that I need to get to that peak
now if you look at PD standard you only
need 4 V CPUs to achieve the max
performance on a PD standard and for PD
SSD you can get up to there with 32 V
CPUs which is pretty aggressive in terms
of spare CPU cycles that you would have
to spend getting to that levels and it's
the slopes are you can get to the peak
with just 32 and psst I'm gonna get I'm
gonna transfer control to Stanley for
more details around performance thank
you man who for the introduction hello
everyone a brief introduction about
myself I walk on performance of the
persistent disk focus on performance of
the disk itself and also try to optimize
performance for different kind of
workloads so today as the first section
will be focusing around performance
recommendations what you can do to best
utilize PD
so let's first start with a brief very
high-level 30,000 feet bill of a
persistent disk architecture as you can
see here you have GC VMs and you have
persistent disk and the shows up has a
disk to the GC VMs which are the
rectangle boxes and to key high-level
takeaways you can have on this graph is
one this PD is a virtualized disk it's a
completely virtualized every copy of
data say for them to look at the blue
copy if you write logical copy to PD
it's sent back down to a massive scale
back and physic
starter system and it's replicated
three-way a three-way equivalent and
then because it's completely virtualized
it does not have the one-to-one mapping
from a logical possessor disk to a
particular physical resource and it
allows us to innovate and if you define
some thought a unique feature that is
unlikely to happen in a completely
physical attached to this court and the
other takeaway you can have on this is
because we're built on top of Google
internal massive scale distributed file
system allows us to scale PD and we do a
lot of optimization for random writes
and also in terms of reads we try to
read from the fastest copy of those
three so move on to some of the
additional details about performance and
these are the details that we actually
mentioned in our documentation but
sometimes we found out a lot of
customers often didn't pay much
attention to those so first for the IRS
and the throughput limits when we
published those limits in order to
measure IRS you use 8 KB iOS or less and
then to measure throughput make sure you
use 256 KB aisles are larger and use
sequential aisles to match and the third
point is very interesting is that we if
you attach multiple discs of the same
type but different sizes to the same VM
the individual disk had actually achieve
the same level of performance as the sum
of those disks for them per if we attach
one tank take about this and then one
one terabyte disk to the same VM that
can pick by disk actually performed at
the same level as one terabyte plus 10t
byte and if you're using a tank about
this only this gives you great
flexibility in terms of iOS and in terms
of how you use doses as long as you buy
enough size you will get those aisles
regardless on which disk you use those
aisles are for the via then the last
point which are we're talking for it
detail in the next slide is about the
concept of duplex duplex means you can
achieve the read/write limit
concurrently as a
so for PD SSDs the throughput limit is
actual duplex that means you can achieve
the reader a limit as document at the
same time and max by the rest of the
other limits like PD standard throughput
is not duplex
I often limit is also duplex let's take
a look at the detail so again this big
table a lot of data is actually copy
pasted from our documentation and
throughout the years and customers have
had questions to us and will ask what
does this mean and what is duplex so I
figure it's worth calling out today and
to just give a quick example and the
introduction and of this concept and so
for duplex means maximum limits for read
and write can be achieved simultaneously
if you look at the lower right corner of
this graph as you can see this table as
you can see it's very easy to understand
for SSD read write throughput limit you
can achieve 240 megabytes
at the same time if you keep hitting the
disk with maximum read and write both
sides can reach 240 now what does not
duplex mean not reflex means you can
take a look at the example of the
standard persistent disk readwrite
limits so if you do read only you can do
240 if you to write only you can do 240
but what happens if you to read a write
at the same time now let's assume if you
have 50% reads 50,000 rights then
proportionately post limits will be
reduced to the middle which is 120 and
120 so that's how you can understand
readwrite mixed and which is called
mount earplugs so of all these limits I
offs limit throughput limits only the PD
SSD throughput limit is 40 plugs so
which is you know you can reach 1.2 g4
reads at max and 400 megabytes for reads
or writes so now let's switch topic to
application level tuning and what you
can do at a high level in your
application to make sure you can fully
utilize the disk so first of all always
try to ensure that your issue enough
concurrent aisles to reach maximal I ops
so the number of concurrent aisles is
sometimes also known as cute as if it is
a file frequent enough you will know the
concept so
always try to ensure qdx of at least one
for every 800 to 1000 IRS for example if
you want to hit 12,000 IRS then you want
to make sure their application can have
at least 15 aisles outstanding at any
time so if you're running on my sequel
database probably that means you
probably want to configure page cleaner
thread to be 15 or above so there will
always be that many iOS outstanding so
for maximum throughput make sure you use
256 KB or larger aisles and do
sequential and forth for your typical
Hadoop workload that shouldn't be a
problem so the next topic is about
enabling discard or trim and for many of
you who have a physical world SSD
experience you know trim command or
discard command is highly recommended
for physical SS device which helps them
to reduce the right amplication effect
and trim is generally also helpful for
better performance for PD although it's
for completely different reason but the
other aspect I want to mention here is
about trim actually helps you to reduce
your persistent disk snapshot size in
the sense that you know if you don't
enable chained what happens is when you
delete a logical file at the file system
level file system just change that
metadata to indicate that file has been
deleted and the fact that those physical
blocks were still appear as used as a PD
layer so if you take a snapshot on the
PD others the data files actually are
also included in your snapshot but if
you enable a trim command and others PDT
file would the little blocks would have
been discarded and your snapshot size
will be much smaller so to enable him
you can do the - oh this third option to
mount so here are few things you don't
have to do to optimize performance for
PD when there's PD is not oven at all
you don't have to preheat it and in the
sense that for example if you download a
restore snapshot to a new PD after the
snapshot restoration is done you can
just start to read from it directly and
it gets full performance and then the
other aspect was a man who just
mentioned a few moments ago is that you
don't need to rate multiple CDs to reach
the maximum performance just
provisioning a large enough PD and that
should give you enough performance and
the last one about in this section is
about and sharing read-only data across
multiple VMs so you can create a PD you
can have like software package so you
want to distribute to pans off the ends
in a zone and those that PD will be in a
read-only mode you can attach that PD
using this command - - mode ro to many
many - a few VMs that turns off the MS
so and then those VMs can are read from
that PD easily and this is suitable for
a small scale distribution of static
content within a zone now if you have a
large spare huge scale distribution if
you want cross don't distribution then
consider using Google Cloud Storage is
this and all if you have file level
sharing especially read/write file share
and then we have a new product called
Google Cloud 5-star you can use so then
of course in this particular scenario PD
SSD is highly recommended here because
you can never see lots of redials to
this shared PD and assessed is more
superb suitable for that purpose okay
the last slide applies if you and happen
to use PD as a lot of ice without
formatting a file system on top of it
it's called missile and writes to
basically make sure that when you do
writes to the raw device the writes is
as always a land at the physical block
size boundary if you look at those 16 KB
or 6 kb writes that's not aligned the
red block are the block of the existing
main content that we have to maintain
the way we have to implement it is - a
process called read modify write in the
sense we have to read the old block and
modify it with your new payload for the
misaligned portion and then write it
back
this makes the write process extremely
slow so alright so now let's move on to
the next section which is about
introducing an example of how you can
optimize a particular workload
I see core database using a new feature
called 16 KB physical block size PD
which is currently in beta so as we
optimize performance and introducing new
features for PD we always keep in mind
that we want to do it that can actually
benefit the real-world application and
of the real-world application my sequel
database application is fairly important
to many of our customers and my sequel
is a very common database application so
let's go over this example and let's go
over what this physical block size 16 KB
physical process PD means so for
persistent what is a physical block size
what it means in the concept of in the
context of persistent disk so for
persistent disk physical block is the
unit at which lights have atomicity
atomic city means you have all or
nothing semantics 16 KB right if it's
aligned if it's written to a 16 KB
physical block size PD you will be
ensured to either write nothing in your
failure case or VN crash or your
application crash you'll write either
nothing all right
oh and as a successful case now the
default physical block size of a
persistent disk is 4 kb + 16 kb physical
block size has just recently been added
like probably a month ago as a beta
feature so then the next question
obviously is what do I use the 16 KB and
PD for and then it is really designed
for my sequel database workload that is
quite heavy
now if you happen to run other databases
and the for ample sequel server or
Oracle and those database if you can
change those database data page size to
be 16 KB and and then use PD and thought
many of those data bits have a mode to
use block storage as a raw device then
you can potentially also benefit from
this 16 KB PD so what's the problem
what's the problem we try to solve at my
secret lair yours with this 16 KB PG
here's a problem here is a typical
OLTP run for those of you who use my
Seco and manages my circle
the Syst bench OLTP is a standard
benchmarking method to run to benchmark
performance of mexico database this is
the 8-hour run with 512 concurrent
connections fairly heavy and as you can
see at the second phase of the run my
access is a performance TPS during
second half of the run the performance
various great ways that database is you
know essentially not that useful to you
and because the performance vary by like
5 X 6 X and all that right so now let's
just do a quick preview on what you can
achieve with a 16 KB PD and configure my
C code to disable that double right
feature and so in the middle of the
graph is the performance after you're
doing 16 KB PD as you can see it's more
stable it's a little bit higher it's a
bit higher than what's a lower right
corner which was before on a 4k DVD and
then this is also our internal
regression test 2 and this is for the
last February and early March the blue
lines here are 16 KB performance on my C
code running on 16 KB PD and the red
lines here my sequel running on 4k BPD
and 16 KB performance is a bit higher
and more stable than the red lines then
the 4 KB ones so okay now let's just
take a little bit deeper for those real
of your hood and never and touched my
secret before this might be boring but
you know let's just see where the
problem is and why is the 16 KB PDI help
solve that problem the problem here is
if internally inside my Seco on this
graph plotted is what caught a flash lag
flashback means that you know how much
lagging behind is that a 30-page flash
versus a log file so here you can see
the my Seco log file has grow to the
ceiling which is a 20 megabytes in this
case and my sequel is in a silk flash
state in that state my secure would not
take new incoming mutations unless it
can find a 30-page to flash Malcolm in
the log file and they take the notation
this leads to the initial problematic
graph where you see huge variation of
performance because the database is the
self isn't in a stop and go
so in order to control flash lag we want
to make sure that the 30 page flash can
be done at a rate that's higher than
incoming right rate then inside my C
code there's an option called double
right if we can disable double right
then that means we can reduce the 30
page flash rate I have essentially
doubling the eye ops you can get on the
30 page flash front so then the next
question will become what is double
right and how does a 16 KB PD help help
you disable that all right so Pavel
right inaudible as a Mexico storage
engine you know DB double right is to
basically when it needs to flush a 30
page and actually write a page twice in
two different locations on disk because
it does it needs to do that is to guard
against a Tom page situation a Tom pagès
situation happens if you write a 16 KB
page on of traditional 4 KB physical
block device during a failure mode maybe
only part of the page may be
successfully written on the disk like
say 4 KB or 8 KB or 12 kg right when
that case happens the pages tone is lost
is partially only partially written you
can't even replace the transaction log
on to that page to reconstruct a new
page because the old page is essentially
overwritten and corrupted so that's why
in ODB needs to write the when the
flashes the 30 page you need to write
twice first hand to a backup buffer cut
and double write buffer the second pen
to the actual place if the second light
is torn and corrupted they can use the
first write to restore it now if we can
build a 16 kV right atomic atomic right
past
font a debase all the way to the disk
then we can avoid the need to do this
kind of double right because all the 16
kV and writes would have been atomic it
will happen end-to-end all the way to
the disk have all or nothing semantics
so that's where you can use 16 KB pd4
here are the list of steps here the
details I'm not going to repeat those
steps you can just Google best practices
for 16 KB persistent disk and my Seco
and those steps were show up in a
document but one quick thing I want to
call out here
is that the ability to create a 16kb
possessive disc is very unique on Google
Cloud it moves back to the initial
architecture graph in that persistent
disk is a fully virtualized storage
block device solution built on top of a
massive distributed file system on the
backend because it's fully utilized it
it's possible that we make this kind of
features that to customize a property
called physical block size that in the
physical world would have been a
attribute of the underlying physical
device that is extremely hard to
customize so here is the 16 KB PD and
here are the steps you can follow to
safely disable my psycho double right
and by using a 16 KB PD one last thing I
want to call out that through other
steps there's a staff mentioning that
you need to use container optimized the
OS which is called cause it's it is a
Google curated and it's supported by a
Google team here and it's designed for
Google compute platform and one thing I
want to mention here is that it is also
used by Google Cloud sequel VMs the
reason we want to use cause image if we
want if you want to use 16 KB for my
Seco is that cause image qualification
process has built-in tests to ensure
that the Linux kernel layers between the
filesystem and the disc do not split
break misaligned the sixth and writes
across 16 KB boundaries so that is how
we ensure there's an end-to-end atomic
16 KB right path all the way to the test
[Music]